[Music]
welcome to the return of the coliseum my
name is roger bolton and i'm
the host for this debate in rome
gladiatorial combat and all
juice with the mainstay of entertainment
while in the modern era
public entertainment was cleansed in
favor of music sport theater and so
forth
the lure of the internet's salacious
content is stronger than ever
where is this new uncharted space taking
our entertainment and our morality with
us are meg rossoff she's a renowned
author with multiple accolades to her
name including
the carnegie medal and the astrid
lindgren memorial award
sir my gosh critic performer and the
founding editor of cult polysexual
magazine
the demented goddess and joanna cavena
is novelist her first novel in glorious
won the orange prize for new writing her
latest novel zed
is an absurdist depiction of life
so we're going to start by asking each
of these three to outline briefly
their position on the questions of
should we see a return to the explicit
desires of the ancients
as a deeply troubling challenge to our
culture
meg rossoff right well
108 million people were killed by wars
in the 20th century
and it's estimated that up to a billion
people have been killed
in wars throughout human history
war it could be argued is the most
extreme expression
of the worst of human impulses but
there is no shortage uh
it starts when you're a child it starts
with playground
bullying if you're not very lucky it
goes on to workplace bullying
in between there's all sorts of stuff
like
the rape and sexual exploitation of
children there's
um coercive control in relationships and
of course on a larger scale there are
things like
religious persecution uh genocide
the pogroms and one of our
favorites of course in history the
inquisition
there's murder and torture and criminal
acts
and more recently there have been the
violent pylon
trolling events that occur on social
media sites
um they're nothing if not wide-ranging
and they
include uh subjects like why a
literature politics
knitting apparently got very involved
with trolling recently
pretty much any subject that you can
possibly name
mary beard was viciously violent and
violently trolled for daring to suggest
and because she is a historian
that the romans were of mixed ethnicity
so it's it seems to me that bad and when
i say bad
i mean lethal sadistic vicious
irrational
and cruel behavior is for whatever
reason
intrinsic to the makeup of the human
brain humans are of course capable of
great acts of kindness
intelligence and positive social action
given the chance
however we know from history and from
our own experience in primary school
that it's best not to encourage human
beings to express themselves anonymously
from a place of ignorance or frustration
or in a forum that allows or plays on
the other ring
of our fellow human beings in which case
i would probably somewhat
controversially suggest that we shut
down
uh twitter right what's going on gosh do
you
see the uh or would you see a return to
the explicit desires of the ancients as
a deeply troubling challenge to our
culture
well there's good explicit
which you might regard as the age of
spectacle
but really began a long time ago um
certainly the romans are an example in
the roman example
we have uh imperialism and we have an
empire
that through spectacle is seeking to
terrorize
subjugate and distract in order to
impose
order interestingly what i
see happening now in um the modern
desire for display and the displayed
life
is uh some choices
um whereby um whereby spectacle
can be performer-led and in that way i
would say
making what is considered to be
bad um explicit um
or or displayed in a way that you are
controlling
um can actually uh deconstruct
sensationalism
and uh use it to highlight
um invisible pain and invisible
injustice and an example i'd give there
would be
lead kantarowicz um the so-called
terrorist [ __ ] superstar
um who is an israeli who willingly
um became a migrant and who takes to the
streets
using porn acts to um
to protest against israeli censorship
and to protest against the plight of the
palestinians
so from my point of view i see
um the i see
repression as a way
of in fact monsterizing
the monstrous so when we say that
something is
bad um we uh begin
to give it uh a particular importance a
particular
shape and we also perform
outrage and these mechanics
are used by the
modern politics of spectacle through
through twitter through tabloids through
click bait it to crush justice
and create mob rule but interestingly
they then they then return us um on the
one hand
to you might think this ancient world of
spectacle but at the same time
if we move to repress
what is being said we're actually
partaking
in a politics of sensationalism so
for me bad explicit and good explicit
are interlinked in this age and it's up
to us to develop some kind of
agency within the modern age of
spectacle
joanna you'd similarly not similarly
actually are you
disturbed by what you now see and and
and fear
a return to the coliseum well i want to
look at this metaphor we're using the
coliseum because i think when we talk
about is it a return to the agents i
think
we have the dilemma that the ancient
world presents
and if you look at the earlier form of
spectacles on the colosseum
it's greek tragedy that's the great
spectacle for the greeks and
greek tragedy is aristotle rights it
works through mimesis
that's the whole point of the tragedy is
that it's an
imitation of real horror real
suffering real violence real death and
you lead the audience into compassion
and then into catharsis that
idea that you're you go through a kind
of ritual and
um there's a kind of purification at the
end with the coliseum it's a really
important
leap or descent i'd argue into
literalism you lose this notion of
metaphor
and poetry and mimesis you think that
the representation and the thing you're
representing have to be the same so
when you represent violence horror
suffering and death
you demand that your so-called
performers are really maimed
they're really tortured they're really
killed
and that completely alters the audience
relationship whereas
in that kind of great mimetic tradition
of tragedy
the audience is moved to compassion for
suffering
if you're watching the coliseum
spectacle and
our contemporary iterations of it you'll
move to cruelty as meg mentioned it's a
huge explosion of cruelty
there's no catharsis because you're kind
of mired in the darkness you don't
emerge from the darkness into this kind
of
light that is that human experience and
so you're left
in this kind of debauchery and as soma
was saying it's also
very much about imperialism and about
power it has that caligular
notion to as well that the pleasure of
those who can control the rebels
who decide what's on the stage is seem
to be greater
in importance than the suffering and
even death
of those who are powerless who have to
be performers you know the gladiators
were you know compelled into these
acts so i think that's a really
important distinction and if we're
vaulting two millennia from that kind of
ancient world into the
internet what we have really is the
internet isn't just one
colosseum it isn't just one amphitheater
one drama you know there's an infinite
array the whole mirror has been
shattered
and you can have any number of coliseums
or theaters
um and any number of audiences and any
number of little mini emperors
determining the rebels
and so there's an infinite array of
possibility but i think
there's a further question and a further
challenge which is about
fake and real if you're talking about
representation and reality and the
difference between them the internet
messes with that in such a a kind of
unusual historical way in that
if you're sitting in the coliseum you're
splattered with gore you see this poor
gladiator dying breathing his last
you know that that's real with the
internet you don't know what's really
have a problem with
is are the rebels real are they fake
and i wonder if the response to that is
a further distrusting of representation
in a way
a further kind of quest for literal fact
for everything to be
verifiable and a furthest dismissing of
that grand or poetic tradition where you
represent
so that would be mine i want the theater
not the colosseum and i want confessions
and compassion
not cruelty but i feel you know
that's also a question about whether you
want art or sort of lump and literalism
as well whether you want to have play
or whether you want to have horror to
continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
you